>>> DID YOU SEE THIS TODAY?
WE'LL SHOW IT TO YOU.
IT IS ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER.
HE POSTED A POUFRL VIDEO MESSAGE
ON TWITTER SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO
THE PEOPLE OF RUSSIA ABOUT THE
HORRORS OF THEIR GOVERNMENT'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
AS A NATIVE OF AUSTRIA, HE SAID
HE'S ALWAYS ADMIRED THE STRENGTH
OF THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE BUT SAID
THEY'RE BEING TRICKED BY PUTIN'S
PROPAGANDA.
>> AS A LONG-TIME FRIEND OF THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE, I HOPE YOU WILL
HEAR WHAT I HAVE TO SAY.
I KNOW THAT YOUR GOVERNMENT HAS
TOLD YOU THAT THIS IS A WAR TO
DENAZIFY UKRAINE.
THIS IS NOT TRUE.
UKRAINE IS A COUNTRY WITH A
JEWISH PRESIDENT, A JEWISH
PRESIDENT, I MIGHT ADD, WHOSE
FATHER, THREE BROTHERS, WERE ALL
MURDERED BY THE NAZIS.
YOU SEE, UKRAINE DID NOT START
THIS WAR.
NEITHER DID NATIONALISTS OR
NAZIS.
THOSE IN POWER IN THE KREMLIN
STARTED THIS WAR.
THIS IS NOT THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE'S
WAR.
>> SCHWARZENEGGER MAKING A
DIRECT APPEAL TO RUSSIAN TROOPS.
>> TO THE SOLDIERS WHO LISTEN TO
THIS, THE 11 MILLION RUSSIANS
HAVE FAMILY CONNECTIONS TO
UKRAINE.
SO EVERY PERSON YOU SHOOT, YOU
SHOOT A BROTHER OR A SISTER.
EVERY BOMB OR SHELL THAT FALLS
IS FALLING NOT AN ENEMY BUT ON A
SCHOOL OR A HOSPITAL OR A HOME.
I KNOW THAT THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE
ARE NOT AWARE OF SUCH THINGS
HAPPENING, SO I URGE THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE AND THE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
IN UKRAINE TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROPAGANDA AND THE
DISINFORMATION THAT YOU ARE
BEING TOLD.
I ASK YOU TO HELP ME SPREAD THE
TRUT